أنا هنا أتشبث بجانب هوة جليدية عميقة
لم أكن أعتقد أنني سأنتهي في أي وقت مضى في
مكان مثل
ألاسكا
هذه الولاية المهيبة تضم
أعلى 13 قمة في الولايات المتحدة على بعد أكثر من 45000
ميل من الخط الساحلي والحياة البرية الوفيرة
أيضًا  لقد كان على قائمة الجرافات الخاصة بي ، لذا
توجهت إلى بلدة سوارد على بعد حوالي
120 ميلاً جنوب المرسى
حيث قابلت صديقي القديم
جنوم ترافيلوسيتي المتجول سعيدًا أنه يمكنك جعله بوب
الآن يمكنك أن تقرر ما إذا كنت هنا
للاسترخاء أو  استكشاف ، هل يمكننا القيام بالأمرين في
الواقع ، لذا قمنا أولاً بالقفز في
رحلة بحرية في الطبيعة
اكتشفنا لماذا لا نذهب بسهولة إلى ألاسكا مع
جولات مضايق كيني التي
نقاتلها عبر مضيق بحري متجه إلى خليج
ألاسكا ، نعم ، لقد أردت دائمًا القدوم
إلى  الدولة التاسعة والأربعون يومًا ما حسنًا ، دعنا
ننتهز يومًا ما اليوم ، أنا جاهز
لأننا خرجنا بحثًا عن
الحوت الأحدب بعيد المنال ، كان المحيط
يعج بالحياة البرية من استيقاظ قطة سوداء
ربما يجب أن أضع
غطاء محركي على خنازير البحر وسيرك من
البفن  عطوف  من المشي حول مثل
هذا ،
واجهنا مستعمرة من
أسود البحر النجمية أكبر أنواع أسد البحر
ويبلغ وزنها ما يصل إلى 2500 رطل ، كان اثنان من
الذكور الكبيرة يتقاتلان على مجموعة
من الإناث تسترخى على الصخور أدناه
اللائي كان من الواضح أن الفائزين هنا ما زالوا
يأملون في  رؤية حوت قمت بتسجيل الوصول إليها
مع القبطان جريج رؤية جيدة جدًا
وفرصة جيدة لرؤية أحد
الحوت الأحدب شمال المحيط الهادئ
يمكن أن ينمو إلى ما يقرب من 60
قدمًا وبينما نتحرك بعيدًا في حديقة كيناي
فيوردز الوطنية بدا أنه
يتغير  الفصول وما
ظهر أمامنا أخيرًا كان يخطف الأنفاس
من نهر ielts الجليدي المائي حيث كان يتدهور وينهار
في البحر ،
لذا أراهن بوب أنك ترغب في الاستيقاظ
فوق أحد هذه الأنهار الجليدية ،
لذلك اتضح أن جنوم المتجول لم
يكن كذلك  مزاح بوب قابل طيارك مايك
من مروحيات الماراثون ، حسنًا ، مايك
أين أنا بالضبط ، لذلك نحن
نطير عبر جبال كيني هنا بالضبط ،
ما هو هذا الجبل الجليدي على وشك زيارته نحن على
استعداد  لقد وضعنا مايك في جودوين الجليدي على سطح
القمر ، والتقينا
مع مرشدنا كيف تفعل أنا
دليل تنفيذ بوب تريفور ، لم أكن أعلم
أن الرجال لديهم سر بالنسبة لي في أعالي
النهر الجليدي
وتحذير متكرر  لا تسقط في
تلك الحفرة ، حسنًا ،
ستموت بالتأكيد إذا وقعت
في تلك الحفرة ،
ثم لسوء حظي اكتشفت أن
الخطة بالنسبة لي هي النزول إلى
حفرة عميقة في الجليد تسمى الصدع يا
إلهي هذا عملي للجميع
أغراض لا قعر لها
ليست في جورجيا بعد الآن ،
الأمر الذي يعيدنا إلى حيث بدأنا
بالأرض نحاول أن تبتلعني
بالكامل أوه بوب الأرض لن
تبتلعك الآن استمتع بنفسك وابدأ في
الصعود مرة أخرى إلى القمة
الجميلة بوب نعم هناك نذهب بلطف  بوب وعلى
الرغم من كل الصعاب ، فقد وصلت إلى
حافة الصدع إلى مشهد مرحب به للغاية
لصديقي العزيز بوب بين أيدينا ، لقد
كنت دائمًا في أمان ، فأنت على حق 100
ولكن لا يزال بإمكانك الاحتفال مثل
ملكك في العالم
[موسيقى]
أنت